From PRI, Public Radio International.
来自PRI，国际公共广播电台。
Public Radio.
公共广播。
Public--
公共——
Radio International.
国际广播。
--Radio International.
——国际广播。
One more time.
再来一次。
The day Sandra should have been dead started like a normal day. She was cutting school with the girls in her gang.
桑德拉本该死掉的那一天，是以平凡的一天开始的。她当时正和帮派里的女孩们一起逃学。
We were standing there, and a group of girls passed us, and they looked at us, and we looked at them. And of course, automatically our mouths flew open without thinking. What are you looking at? Oh, you got something? What do you be about? And started asking them what their affiliation is, and other stuff. And we started talking [BLEEP] to them and other stuff. And they pulled out a gun, and they said OK, you want to talk [BLEEP] now? Let's talk [BLEEP]. And I panicked. I mean, nobody had ever pulled a gun on  me. I was like, holy [BLEEP], and I just started kind of running around, and I was like, oh my god, they're going to kill us. They're actually going to kill us. It had finally sunk in that somebody was going to kill us, that that would be it, the end of my life. At like 14, somebody was going to kill me.
我们站在那儿，一群女孩从我们身边经过，她们看着我们，我们也看着她们。当然，我们不假思索地脱口而出。你们看什么看？噢，你们有什么毛病吗？你们是混哪儿的？我们开始问她们属于哪个帮派之类的。我们开始对她们说些刻薄的脏话。然后她们掏出了一把枪，说，好啊，你们现在想说脏话是吧？那咱们就说个够。我当时惊慌失措。我是说，从来没有人拿枪指着我。我当时心想，天哪，我开始四处乱跑，我当时想，天哪，她们要杀了我们。她们真的要杀了我们。我终于意识到有人要杀我们，那将是我的生命尽头。我才14岁，竟然有人要杀我。
And it kind of flashed in my mind that here comes my mother finding me on the street corner with a bullet through my head and blood gushing everywhere, and oh my god. So everybody just kind of spread out, and I ran, and I lost my shoes, and my jacket, my purse. I lost everything. I was just like throwing things off me to make me lighter so I could run faster. And finally I jumped into a dumpster, and I stood there. And I must have stood there a good hour, hour and a half. And I just stood there and prayed and shaked, and tried to not make noise. And I heard them run past me, and run past me, and screaming "bitch" and looking for people. And I was there, and I was praying to God that they didn't open the dumpster and find me, because if they would have, I think I would have been dead.
我脑子里闪过一个画面，我妈妈在街角发现了我，我头部中弹，血流满地，噢，天哪。所以大家四散奔逃，我跑着跑着，鞋子、夹克、钱包都掉了。我失去了一切。我当时只是把东西扔掉，好让自己跑得更快。最后我跳进了一个垃圾箱，缩在那里。我一定在那里站了整整一个小时到一个半小时。我就站在那儿，祈祷着，浑身发抖，尽量不发出声音。我听见她们从我身边跑过去，又跑回来，尖叫着骂着脏话，到处找人。我就在那儿，向上帝祈祷她们不要打开垃圾箱发现我，因为如果她们发现了，我想我就死定了。
In movies and books, when somebody nearly dies it changes them. You know? They mend their ways. They treat people better. But in real life, it can go either way. Sandra waited and finally walked home alone, smelling like garbage, unrepentant.
在电影和书中，当某人死里逃生时，这会改变他们。你知道吗？他们会改过自新。他们会更好地对待他人。但在现实生活中，结果可能会向任何方向发展。桑德拉等了一会儿，最后独自走回家，身上散发着垃圾的味道，毫无悔意。
And my mother asked me, where's your shoes and your purse and your jacket and everything? And I told her that these girls were going to beat us up. I lied and I said that they started talking to us. They were gang-bangers. I told her like that, that they were gang-bangers, and they were looking for trouble. Knowing full well--
我妈问我，你的鞋子、钱包、夹克还有其他东西呢？我告诉她，是那些女孩要打我们。我撒了谎，说她们先来招惹我们。她们是帮派成员。我就是这么告诉她的，说她们是帮派分子，是来找麻烦的。我心里很清楚——
Yeah, knowing full well.
是的，你心里很清楚。
Knowing full well that I was the one that started it, and that I was gang-banging.
我很清楚是我先挑起的争端，而且我才是那个混帮派的人。
But even after that you didn't quit the gang.
但即使经历了那件事，你也没有退出帮派。
No. Why? A lot of different answers why. We didn't get hurt. We got to go back and tell our story. And none of us said that we hid. You know, none of us said we hid.
没有。为什么？有很多不同的原因。我们没有受伤。我们回去讲述了我们的故事。我们谁也没有说我们躲起来了。你知道，我们谁也没说。
What did you say?
你们说了什么？
We said that we outran them.
我们说我们跑得比她们快。
As if that's more heroic.
好像那样显得更英勇似的。
It's better than saying I hid in the garbage can. That's cowardly.
总比说我躲在垃圾桶里强。那太懦弱了。
But outrunning them is still just as fleeing.
但跑得快也同样是逃跑。
But they had a gun. It's fleeing, but it's honorable fleeing.
但她们有枪。那是逃跑，但那是体面的逃跑。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, stories of people who thought they were about to die, and how it affected them or didn't affect them. Act One, the day after Kevin slept on the spot Jesus was crucified. Act Two, the day Lawrence left the AIDS clinic for the big road trip. Act Three, the day Claudia asked her brother some questions. Act Four, the day Cheryl got the news. Act Five, the day Matthew saw Brigid. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目讲述了一些人以为自己即将死去的故事，以及这如何影响了他们，或者说，如何没有影响他们。第一幕，凯文睡在耶稣受难地点的第二天。第二幕，劳伦斯离开艾滋病诊所去远行。第三幕，克劳迪娅问她哥哥一些问题。第四幕，谢丽尔得到消息的那天。第五幕，马修见到布里吉德的那天。请继续收听。
Act One. So what if you knew? What if you really knew the date and time of your own death? Well, Kevin Kelly spent most of his twenties wandering around Asia. He was a freelance photographer. And he found himself photographing a lot of religious ceremonies. He found himself drawn to religious ceremonies. He was confused about what he believed.
第一幕。如果你知道会怎样？如果你真的知道自己死亡的日期和时间，会怎样？凯文·凯利二十多岁的大部分时间都在亚洲漫游。他是一名自由摄影师。他发现自己拍摄了很多宗教仪式。他发现自己被宗教仪式所吸引。他对自己所信仰的东西感到困惑。
I would get twisted and caught up, and these things were sort of in the background consuming me. Actually I found that I could think about little else for many, many months, that behind all that I was doing there was always this unresolved question of was God real? If he was real, then how could we ignore him? And if we were trying to not ignore him, what do we do? And if he was real, then what about these other things that people said about God?
我会感到纠结和迷茫，这些事情在某种程度上在背景中消耗着我。实际上我发现，在过去的许多个月里，我几乎无法思考其他事情，我所做的一切背后总有一个悬而未决的问题：上帝是真的吗？如果他是真的，那我们怎么能忽视他？如果我们努力不忽视他，我们该做什么？如果他是真的，那人们关于上帝的其他说法又是怎么回事呢？
But all that changed. When he was 27, he came into Jerusalem. It was the weekend of both Easter and Passover, and the city was flooded with tourists.
但一切都变了。当他27岁时，他来到了耶路撒冷。那是复活节和逾越节的周末，城里挤满了游客。
So I entered Jerusalem on Easter with the simple expectation that I was going to photograph yet another religious ceremony, another religious festival. And then for various reasons I got locked out of my hostel room. They had a curfew, and I didn't make it back in time. And I was in quite a fix because I was a stranger in this very strange town. When it happened, I didn't have enough money to stay elsewhere, nor did I even have knowledge of where to go.
所以，我带着一个简单的期望在复活节进入了耶路撒冷，那就是去拍摄又一个宗教仪式，又一个宗教节日。然后由于各种原因，我被锁在了旅舍房间外。他们有宵禁，我没赶得回去。我陷入了困境，因为我是在这个非常陌生的城镇里的一个陌生人。事情发生时，我没有足够的钱去别处住宿，甚至不知道该去哪儿。
So I wandered the old town of Jerusalem at night, which had been shuttered up and was like a time machine. It was if I had been transported back into the 15th century, because all the souvenir vendors were gone, and what was left were the labyrinthine paths of cobbled passageways. And I wandered around for a number of hours, and it was getting colder. Eventually I found myself at the one place that was still open, which was some of the churches. And particularly I finally settled into the Church of the Holy Sepulchre, which is called and viewed as the church built over the mound where Jesus Christ was crucified.
所以我整夜在耶路撒冷的旧城徘徊，那里已经关门闭户，就像一台时间机器。仿佛我被传送回了15世纪，因为所有的纪念品小贩都走了，剩下的只有鹅卵石铺就的迷宫般的小巷。我徘徊了几个小时，天气越来越冷。最后我发现自己来到了唯一一个还开着的地方，那就是一些教堂。我最终定下心来，待在圣墓教堂，人们认为这座教堂是建立在耶稣基督受难的土墩之上的。
And I was getting very tired, and there weren't many people around. And so eventually I laid myself out on about the only flat area that was left, which was this marble slab underneath some pendants that had incense on them. And this was presumably the slab that commemorated the exact position of the crosses. So I slept there. I slept on the crucifixion spot that night because it was the only place. There was no place in the inn.
我感到非常疲惫，周围没有几个人。于是我最终躺在仅剩的一块平坦区域上，那是挂着香炉的吊灯下的一块大理石板。这大概就是纪念十字架确切位置的石板。所以我睡在那儿。那天晚上我睡在受难地点，因为那是唯一的地方。客店里没有地方。
I slept there until early morning, when the activities started to increase, and people started coming in. And I went out and followed the crowd where it was going when they were going out to the tombs area in Jerusalem. And I went out, and there were some folding chairs set up in front of this tomb area. And as the sun was coming up on that Easter morning, I was staring at empty tombs.
我一直睡到清晨，活动开始增多，人们开始进来。我走出去，跟着人群去了耶路撒冷的墓地区域。我走到外面，墓地前摆着一些折叠椅。当复活节的早晨太阳升起时，我正凝视着空坟墓。
And for a reason that I cannot comprehend, as I sat on that chair contemplating this view of the early sun morning coming into the empty tombs, all that I had been wrestling with for the past many, many years in thinking about religion sort of became resolved in my mind. And at that very moment, I believed that Jesus Christ has indeed risen from those tombs.
出于某种我无法理解的原因，当我坐在那把椅子上凝视着清晨的阳光照进空坟墓时，过去多年来我在宗教思考上一直纠结的所有问题，在我的脑海中都得到了解决。就在那一刻，我相信耶稣基督确实从坟墓中复活了。
In an instant the tension of trying to figure things out was resolved, because now suddenly everything was figured out. It was as if you had been working on a problem for a long time, and suddenly the answer was there, and it was very clear that was the answer. And although there were many things that were still not clear to you, you were very certain that you were on the right path.
那一瞬间，试图弄清事情真相的紧张感消失了，因为现在一切都突然明朗了。就像你长时间解决一个难题，答案突然就出现了，而且很清楚这就是答案。虽然还有很多事情你仍然不清楚，但你非常确定自己走在正确的道路上。
Having that realization that I believe that Jesus Christ had actually risen from those tombs did not settle 1,001 other things about what one was supposed to do with that, what I was supposed to do with that. Did that mean I was supposed to be a monk? Did that mean I was supposed to be an evangelist? Did  that mean that I had to immediately renounce all that I had and get into sackcloth and ashes and march out into the desert? All of that was left unopened, and that is in fact what occupied my mind as I went back to my hostel to lay down and think about, because I had no clue what it really meant to me ultimately.
虽然我相信耶稣基督确实从坟墓中复活了，但这并没有解决关于一个人应该用这个事实做什么的其他一千零一件事，我应该用它做什么？那意味着我应该成为一名僧侣吗？那意味着我应该成为一名传教士吗？那意味着我必须立即放弃我所有的一切，披上麻布，撒上灰烬，走进沙漠吗？所有这些问题都没有答案，而这确实占据了我的思绪，当我回到旅舍躺下思考时，因为我完全不知道这对我最终意味着什么。
And that's what I was pondering when I sort of was laying there napping. And I wouldn't say it's a voice, but there was an idea that came into my mind that just would not go away. And that was that I should live as if I would die in six months, that I should really truly live. And that I could not tell for certain whether I would really die, but that either way I should live as if I was going to die. And so that was the assignment.
当我躺在那儿小睡时，我就是在琢磨这些。我不会说这是一个声音，但我的脑海中产生了一个念头，而且挥之不去。那就是我应该像只剩六个月生命一样生活，我应该真正地生活。我无法确定我是否真的会死，但无论如何，我都应该像我就要死了一样生活。这就是那个使命。
I'm a pretty rational person. I'm pretty logical. And after thinking the thought that I should live as if I was going to die in six months, the first thought that comes to my head was, well that's pretty silly. You have no evidence whatsoever. I could live like I'm going to die in six months and not die at all. It would just be kind of an interesting exercise. But at the same time, it was equally probable that I might die in six months. It happened all the time. There was no guarantee that I wouldn't die. And so fairly quickly I decided that I could not settle that issue of whether I would really die or not, or just think that I was going to die in six months. And that in either case, the important thing was to live as if I really believed that I was going to die in six months. Which is what I set out to do.
我是一个非常理性的人。我非常讲逻辑。在想到我应该像只剩六个月生命一样生活这个念头后，我脑海中出现的第一个想法是，好吧，这太蠢了。你没有任何证据。我可能像只剩六个月生命一样生活，却根本没死。这只会是一种有趣的练习。但与此同时，我确实可能在六个月内死去。这种情况时有发生。没人保证我不会死。于是我很快决定，我无法解决我是否真的会死的问题，或者只是认为我会在六个月内死去。无论哪种情况，重要的是像我真的相信我会死一样去生活。这就是我开始去做的事情。
The next couple days had a kind of joyous experience of saying, OK, what do I do for six months if I have only six months to live? And the answers to that surprised me as much as the assignment. Because after thinking that through and contemplating it, the conclusion that I came to was that what I wanted to do for six months was to go home and be ordinary, to go back to my parents, to help them take out the trash and trim the hedges and move furniture around, and to be with them.
接下来的几天，有一种快乐的体验，那就是，“好吧，如果我只有六个月的生命，我该做什么？”这些问题的答案让我和这个使命一样感到惊讶。因为在深思熟虑之后，我得出的结论是，我想在那六个月里做的是回家，过平凡的生活，回到父母身边，帮他们倒垃圾、修剪树篱、搬动家具，和他们待在一起。
And I was really shocked by that, because I thought that with six months to live I would climb Mount Everest, or I would go scuba diving to the depths of the ocean, or get in a speedboat and see how fast I could go. But instead I wanted to go back home and be with my family for that time.
我对此感到非常震惊，因为我原以为，如果只有六个月生命，我会去攀登珠穆朗玛峰，或者潜入深海，或者跳上一艘快艇看看能跑多快。但相反，我只想回家和我的家人共度那段时间。
I, of course, did not tell anybody my crazy idea. This is, in fact, the first time I'm really talking about it publicly, because it was a very scary and sort of alarming idea, and I never told anybody why I was coming home.
当然，我没有把这个疯狂的想法告诉任何人。事实上，这是我第一次公开谈论它，因为它是一个非常可怕且令人不安的想法，我从未告诉过任何人我为什么回来。
I got back to where my parents live in New Jersey, and things were unbelievably ordinary. And yet I found myself relishing the ordinariness and finding it in some ways as exotic as anything that I had traveled to see. And so I was involved in-- I helped around the house. I dug up shrubs. I worked on a deck. I moved furniture, washed dishes, and I was intending to kind of spend my last remaining six months at home getting to know my parents better, and myself hopefully.
我回到了父母居住的新泽西州，一切都不可思议地平凡。然而，我发现自己非常享受这种平凡，并觉得它在某种程度上和我去过任何地方一样充满异国情调。所以我参与其中——我在家里帮忙。我挖灌木。我修整露台。我搬动家具、洗碗，我打算把剩下的六个月花在家里，更好地了解我的父母，也希望更好地了解自己。
But about three months into that, my travel urges I guess got the better of me. And what I was most concerned about is I wanted to see my brothers and sisters. I had four brothers and sisters, and they were scattered all across the country. And so I felt very strongly that I wanted to see them before I died. And I got the idea that the way to see them was to ride my bicycle across the country and visit them on bicycle.
但在那之后大约三个月，我的旅行欲望我想还是战胜了我。我最关心的是我想见我的兄弟姐妹。我有四个兄弟姐妹，他们散居在全国各地。所以我强烈地感到，在去世前我想见见他们。我产生了一个想法，去见他们的方法就是骑自行车穿越全国，骑自行车拜访他们。
But before I did that, I made up a will to dispose of the little things that I had. And I had some money left over, and one of the things that I did with that money was I went to the bank and got some cashier's checks for like $500 and $1,000. And I mailed the money to various people anonymously as gifts. And I think giving away those thousands of dollars was the first true act of charity I had ever done, because there was absolutely no way for any kind of gratitude or elevated feelings to come back to me, because people had no idea who had sent them that money.
但在我这样做之前，我立了一份遗嘱，处理我所拥有的一点点东西。我剩下了一些钱，我用这些钱做的事情之一就是去银行买了一些面值500美元和1000美元的现金支票。我匿名把这些钱作为礼物寄给了不同的人。我认为捐出那几千美元是我做过的第一次真正的慈善行为，因为根本不可能有任何感激或崇高的感觉回馈给我，因为人们根本不知道是谁寄给他们那笔钱的。
It was really remarkable to see the consequences of getting an anonymous gift like that, because when you get a check for $1,000 in the mail, you immediately become suspicious of all your friends of having given it to you. And so there's this sort of like the suspicion of charity, suspicion of goodness, that starts to infect the people that are around you. And you look at someone, you think, hmm, I wonder if he gave me that $1,000?
看到收到这种匿名礼物的结果真的非常了不起，因为当你收到一张1000美元的支票时，你立刻会怀疑是不是你所有的朋友给你的。所以这种对慈善的怀疑，对善意的怀疑，开始感染你周围的人。你看着某人，心想，嗯，不知道是不是他给了我那1000美元？
I had enough money left over to basically pay for food and whatnot on my bicycle journey across America. And the path that I had to visit all my brothers and sisters was not a direct route of going from San Francisco to New York. I actually had to go up to Idaho and back down to Texas, and then back up through Indiana. So it was a 5,000 mile trip.
我剩下的钱基本上够我骑自行车横穿美国的食物开销。为了拜访我所有的兄弟姐妹，路线不是从旧金山到纽约的直达路线。我实际上不得不绕道爱达荷州，再回到德克萨斯州，然后再绕道印第安纳州。所以这是一次5000英里的旅程。
The day, which coincidentally was exactly six months from when I had this assignment, was October 31, was Halloween. And so the plan would be that I would ride back home so that I would come back to die on the day after Halloween.
那一天，巧合的是距离我接到这个使命整整六个月，是10月31日，万圣节。所以计划是，我会骑车回家，这样我就会在万圣节的第二天死掉。
I think there are a lot of people who have trouble staying in the present. There are some people who like to slip into the past as a means to perhaps fantasize or escape, and they find that the past is the place that they retreat to. And I often retreat to the future. I was not a person who planned or had a career staged out, or who had a particular woman he wanted to marry someday, or some vision of a house. The future that I found so hard to give up was a much more insidious type. It was that of-- I like to buy this record because in the future I want to hear the song again and again. Or I will read this book, and there's some cool ideas in it because someday I may write an article about this, and it's kind of good to know that.
我想有很多人很难活在当下。有些人喜欢沉浸在过去，作为幻想或逃避的一种手段，他们发现过去是他们退守的地方。而我经常退守到未来。我不是那种会做计划、有事业规划、或者有某个想在某天娶的女人、或者对房产有某种愿景的人。我发现很难放弃的未来是一种更阴险的类型。那就是——我买这张唱片是因为在未来我想一遍又一遍地听这首歌。或者我会读这本书，里面有一些很酷的想法，因为总有一天我可能会写一篇关于这个的文章，知道这一点感觉挺好的。
There was a sense in which my entire life was shifted to the future, and the thought of sort of doing something now for the enjoyment or the pleasures or the principle of the function of just right now, without any sense at all that it would ever be used again or that it could ever be brought forward, was extremely difficult and disconcerting. And I fought it day by day, and tooth by tooth.
在某种意义上，我的整个人生都转移到了未来，而那种为了此时此刻的乐趣、快乐或纯粹的功能原则去做某事，完全没有任何它会被再次使用或可能被带到未来的念头，这极其困难且令人不安。我一天天地抗争，咬牙坚持。
One of the ways I dealt with this was that I was actually able by the last weeks to not think about my life beyond Halloween. There was a way in which I had just-- each time a thought came up about something that was beyond this horizon, I just said, nope, can't think about, it doesn't work. We have to dwell in the present. And at the same time I was doing that-- and I was able to do that-- I also decided that it was entirely unnatural and inhumane way to live, and that having a future is part of what being human is about, and that when you take away the future for humans, you take away a lot of their humanness. And that it's not actually a very good thing to live entirely in the present, that one needs to have a past, and one needs to have a future to be fully human.
我处理这个问题的方法之一是，在最后几周，我实际上能够不去想万圣节之后的生活。每当有一个关于超出这个范围的想法出现时，我就会说，不，不能想，那行不通。我们必须活在当下。同时我也决定，这是一种极其不自然和非人道的生活方式，拥有未来是身为人类的一部分，当你夺走人类的未来时，你也夺走了他们很大一部分人性。而完全活在当下实际上并不是一件好事，一个人需要有过去，也需要有未来才能成为一个完整的人。
So he bicycled across the country, and as he did he found himself increasingly obsessed with death, with dying. He was making drawings and writing haikus along the way, and as he went across the country, they became more and more dark, more and more preoccupied with death. And as he traveled across the country, the other thing is that he always had to find a place to stay every night. And at first he just tried what he had done in Jerusalem. That is, he would just find a church, and he would camp out on the church lawn. But people got upset at that.
所以他骑车横跨了全国，随着旅程的推进，他发现自己越来越痴迷于死亡，痴迷于死去。一路上他在画画和写俳句，随着他横跨全国，这些内容变得越来越阴暗，越来越沉溺于死亡。在他横跨全国的过程中，另一件事是他必须每天晚上找个地方住。起初他只是尝试他在耶路撒冷做过的事。也就是说，他会找个教堂，在教堂草坪上露营。但人们对此很不高兴。
And so what he decided to do instead is that at each town that he would come into, he would find some quiet residential street. And he'd go up to a house, and he'd say hi, this is who I am. I'm bicycling across the country. I've just eaten dinner, he would say so they wouldn't feel obligated to feed him. Can I camp out in back? And invariably they would say yes, and invariably they would also at some point invite him in for coffee.
所以他决定这样做，在每个城镇，他都会找一条安静的住宅街道。他会走到一户人家，说你好，我是谁谁谁。我正在骑车横跨全国。我已经吃过晚饭了，他说，这样他们就不会觉得有义务喂他。我能在后院扎营吗？他们总是会说可以，而且总是会在某个时候邀请他进去喝杯咖啡。
So I would spend my evenings with entirely ordinary people, and my job at that point was to tell them my story. It was to tell them how great a time I was having, because if I wasn't having a great time they were really disappointed, because I was riding for them. I was vicariously doing what they had always wanted their lives to do, and so the more I enjoyed my time, and the more in the present I was living, the more they enjoyed it, and the more it uplifted them. And so that was basically my job.
所以我会在晚上和完全普通的人待在一起，我那时的任务就是给他们讲我的故事。讲我过得有多开心，因为如果我过得不开心，他们会非常失望，因为我是替他们骑行的。我替代性地做了他们一直想要生活做的事，所以正如我享受我的时光，正如我生活在当下，他们就越享受，这也就越提升他们。所以那基本上就是我的工作。
It was a journey that began at the tomb of Jesus, and as I set off to my own presumed death, I did indeed think about Jesus Christ. We have the history in the Gospels of Jesus' torment in his soul as he approached what he knew of his anointed time to die. So it was again that very harsh information of knowing when you're going to die. And Jesus' soul was in great turmoil and pain because of knowing that. And I think I did experience some of that, not because I had the same weight. That was just my own life. But Jesus prayed that this burden be lifted, and there were days when I did pray that, that if I didn't have to die, I really would rather not.
那是一段始于耶稣之墓的旅程，当我踏上我预想的死亡之路时，我确实想到了耶稣基督。我们在福音书中读到耶稣在接近他所知的受膏死期时，灵魂受到的折磨。这又是那种知道自己何时会死的残酷信息。耶稣的灵魂因为知道这一点而陷入了巨大的动荡和痛苦。我想我确实经历了一些那种痛苦，不是因为我有同样的重担。那只是我自己的生活。但耶稣祈求这重担能够免去，确实有几天我祈祷过，如果我不必死，我真的宁愿不死。
By late fall I was pedaling through the Appalachians, and it was getting colder and colder, and my hands were freezing on the bicycles, and there was ice on my tents in the morning when I got up. And as each day went on, I was coming closer and closer to terrain that I was familiar with and that felt like home. And I was riding into New Jersey, and I was elated. I was elated that I had accomplished this long journey, and I was elated that I was home to see my parents.
到了深秋，我正在穿越阿巴拉契亚山脉，天气越来越冷，我在自行车上的双手冻僵了，每天早上起来帐篷上都有冰。随着每一天过去，我越来越接近我熟悉的、感觉像家的地形。我骑进了新泽西州，我欣喜若狂。我欣喜若狂是因为我完成了这段漫长的旅程，我欣喜若狂是因为我回家见到了我的父母。
And I came into their house on Halloween day, and I was so filled with ideas and things and emotions that I didn't really say very much. And again, I couldn't say very much. I think we had a wonderful dinner. They were, of course, glad to see me, because they hadn't seen me in a long time. They knew I was coming back, and we had a wonderful dinner. We had baskets of candy which I gave out to the kids.
万圣节那天我回到家，我充满了想法、事物和情绪，以至于我没有说太多话。再次强调，我无法说太多。我想我们吃了一顿很棒的晚餐。他们当然很高兴见到我，因为他们很久没见我了。他们知道我会回来，我们吃了一顿美妙的晚餐。我们有几篮糖果，我发给了孩子们。
And we had a discussion that night which was about nothing in particular. It was not about the future. It was just about I think talking about our family, and my brothers and sisters, and I was telling them all that I had learned about them. And so it was a very together and, again, not a very dramatic evening, but just a pleasant one, the kind of one that you might have a memory about as you were dying. It was not a special evening, but just an ordinary evening.
那天晚上我们进行了一场谈话，谈的内容没什么特别的。不是关于未来。我想只是谈谈我们的家庭，我的兄弟姐妹，我告诉他们我所了解的所有关于他们的事。所以这是一个非常团结，再次强调，不是一个非常戏剧性的夜晚，而是一个愉快的夜晚，那种你临终时可能会回忆起的夜晚。这不是一个特别的夜晚，只是一个平凡的夜晚。
And I went to bed that night, which was a very difficult thing to do, because I was fully prepared at that point never to wake up again. I had been praying. I had gotten everything arranged. And at that point I'd fully gone through in my own mind, my own soul, all the things that I might have regretted, and I had righted as many of those as I thought I could through letters. And I was prepared as much as anybody could be prepared to die.
那天晚上我上床睡觉了，这非常困难，因为在那一刻我已做好了准备永远不再醒来。我一直在祈祷。我把一切都安排好了。那时我在自己的脑海中、在自己的灵魂深处，把所有我可能后悔的事情都回顾了一遍，通过信件我尽可能地纠正了它们。我做好了任何能做准备的人所能做好的死亡准备。
So I went to bed while the kids were still ringing the doorbells. And I went to sleep, because I was very tired after that long trip. And I didn't know what was going to happen the next day. I thought that I had done all that I could.
所以当孩子们还在按门铃时，我就上床睡觉了。我睡着了，因为那次长途跋涉后我非常疲惫。我不知道第二天会发生什么。我想我已经尽了我所能做的一切。
And the next morning I woke up. And the next morning I woke up, and it was if-- the next morning I woke up, and it was if I had my entire life again. The next morning I woke up, and I had my entire life again. I had my future again. There was nothing special about the day. It was another ordinary day. I was reborn into ordinariness, but what more could one ask for?
第二天早上我醒了。第二天早上我醒了，就好像——第二天早上我醒了，就好像我又拥有了整个人生。第二天早上我醒了，我又拥有了整个人生。我又拥有了未来。这一天没有什么特别的。这是又一个平凡的一天。我重生于平凡，但一个人还能要求什么呢？
Nearly two decades after that happened, Kevin Kelly is now the executive editor of a magazine about the future, Wired magazine.
在那件事发生近二十年后，凯文·凯利现在是一家关于未来杂志《连线》杂志的执行编辑。
Coming up, more people who nearly died and what they made of it, in a minute when our program continues.
接下来，更多濒临死亡的人以及他们的感悟，一会儿节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and performers and documentary producers to tackle that theme. Today's program, Should Have Been Dead, stories of people who thought they were going to die and what they learned or did not learn from the experience.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、表演者和纪录片制作人来探讨这个主题。今天的节目，《本该死掉的人》，讲述了一些人以为自己即将死去，以及他们从这段经历中学到了什么，或者没学到什么。
We're at Act Two of our program, Maybe Six Months. Well, Lawrence Steger is a filmmaker and a performance artist here in Chicago, and I told him about Kevin Kelly's story. And it turned out that, like Kevin Kelly, at the moment that Lawrence thought he'd glimpsed the possible end of his life, Lawrence also set out on a big trip.
我们进入了节目的第二幕，《或许六个月》。劳伦斯·斯蒂格是芝加哥的一名电影制作人和表演艺术家，我告诉了他凯文·凯利的故事。结果发现，就像凯文·凯利一样，在劳伦斯以为自己瞥见了生命尽头的瞬间，劳伦斯也开始了一次大旅行。
Title-- Road. Treatment-- it's shot entirely on video, mostly handheld, shaky, out of focus, bad color, overblown color actually.
片名——《公路》。处理——它完全用视频拍摄，大多手持，摇晃，失焦，颜色糟糕，实际上是过度饱和的颜色。
Can I get this microphone adjusted a little so I don't have to lean over so much?
能把这个麦克风调一下吗，这样我就不用弯腰那么多了？
Yeah, sure.
好的，没问题。
Check, one, two, three.
一、二、三，试音。
Synopsis-- the story concerns Luke-- gay, white, Midwestern, late twenties-- follows Luke on the day that he is informed of his HIV-positive status. Luke cops a stance of cold, brittle, not unlike the Harrison Ford narration on Blade Runner, but there's a hint of vulnerability to Luke. Have we got the Harrison Ford or the Rutger Hauer voice?
太棒了，压低一点。很好。
Yeah.
梗概——这个故事关乎卢克——男同性恋、白人、中西部人、二十岁出头——讲述了卢克得知自己HIV呈阳性的那一天。卢克摆出一种冷漠、生硬的姿态，和《银翼杀手》里哈里森·福特的旁白没什么两样，但卢克身上有一丝脆弱。我们要哈里森·福特的声音还是鲁特格·豪尔的声音？
Great, roll it.
好的。
Enhance 57 19. Track 45 left.
太棒了，开拍。
Great, take it under me. That's great.
增强57 19。追踪45左。
Story follows Luke. He's accompanied by his college buddy Bill, and both are packed for a road trip across the country to San Francisco.
好，在我之下处理。很好。
Let's just kill the Blade Runner.
故事跟随卢克。他由大学好友比尔陪同，两人都收拾行囊准备横跨全国前往旧金山。
Locations-- car interior, gas station exterior, HIV clinic parking lot, HIV clinic interior, highway. The music is Strauss' "Four Last Songs," particularly "Ruhe, meine Seele" sung by Dame Janet Baker.
把《银翼杀手》的声音去掉。
OK, can you take it under me? Hold.
地点——汽车内部、加油站外部、艾滋病诊所停车场、艾滋病诊所内部、高速公路。音乐是施特劳斯的《最后四首歌》，尤其是珍妮特·贝克夫人演唱的《安息吧，我的灵魂》。
Follows Luke and his friend Bill to the gas station and to the clinic.
好，你能在我下面压低声音吗？保持。
OK, take it out. Take out the Janet Baker.
跟随卢克和他的朋友比尔去加油站，然后去诊所。
Bill loads one-hits of pot while driving on the way to the gas station into the clinic.
好，拿掉它。去掉珍妮特·贝克的音乐。
Can we nix that Strauss music? It's kind of too mournful. There's really no music on the soundtrack. It's stark, crisp, maybe some songs coming from the radio at the clinic's desk. Great. And definitely from the car radio, mixed with surfing on an AM radio. No music.
比尔在去往加油站和诊所的路上边开车边抽大麻烟。
The drama is constantly being undermined through the cool, collective quality of Luke's demeanor. He seems detached. Quote, "I'm not sure how I feel. I feel a little sad, sort of mad. I guess blank, but I'm OK." End quote.
能把那段施特劳斯的音乐去掉吗？太悲伤了。原声带里实际上没有什么音乐。它冷静、清脆，或许诊所前台的广播里有些歌曲。很好。绝对要从车载广播里传出来，混合着调频收音机的搜台声。没有音乐。
Luke thinks he's sounding like a short story assignment in a creative writing class, or worse, trapped inside an artsy novel. Luke imagines himself in a television dramatization of himself. Camera pulls back from behind Luke's head, sort of on a mini-crane. Camera floats, hovers over the back of Luke's head. The ceiling of the car must be incredibly high, he thinks to himself.
剧情不断地被卢克那种冷漠的举止所破坏。他显得很疏离。引文：“我不知道我感觉如何。我感到有点难过，有点生气。我猜是空白，但我还好。”引文结束。
Bill pulls into the closest parking spot in the clinic, blows out the last of the one-hit, and as he's knocking the brass pipe into the ashtray, turns to Luke with that slightly watery look in his eyes from too much intake. Luke takes it as one of those Care Bear looks that he's experienced before from Bill. There's a moment of anger flashing in Luke when he registers Bill's look. When Bill asks him, "What are you thinking about?" Luke responds, "Who's thinking? Nothing." I hate thinking I'm in a novel, he thinks to himself.
卢克觉得听起来像创意写作课上的短篇小说作业，或者更糟，被困在了一本艺术化的小说里。卢克想象自己出现在自己生活的电视连续剧里。摄影机在小型起重机上，从卢克头后方拉远。摄影机浮动，盘旋在卢克后脑勺上方。他心想，车顶一定高得不可思议。
Cut to interior of the clinic, the reception area. Can we change this sound bed here? Great. Take it down just it's a little-- great.
比尔把车停在诊所最近的停车位，呼出最后一口烟雾，当他把黄铜烟斗敲向烟灰缸时，他转头看向卢克，眼神里带着一丝因吸食过量而产生的湿润。卢克将其视为他以前从比尔那里感受到的那种“爱心熊”式的眼神。当卢克注意到比尔的目光时，心中闪过一丝愤怒。当比尔问他：“你在想什么？”卢克回答道：“谁在想？什么也没想。”他心里暗想，我讨厌那种觉得自己身处小说中的感觉。
The nurse assigned to Luke's anonymous number is a black drag queen named Stephanie who wears a full nurse's outfit complete with a little paper hat that sits atop of her freshly coiffed hairdo. She's the only one in the clinic who wears a real uniform. Stephanie has the longest fingernails that Luke has ever seen on anyone. Luke thinks briefly about how the fingernails keep on growing even after a person dies, but he pushes that thought away with his fingers to his forehead, wonders why he's thinking about that. It's that novel thing again.
转场至诊所内部，接待区。我们能改变这里的音效吗？很好。压低一点——很好。
Stephanie, the drag queen nurse, walks Luke back to the small cubicles that the tests are administered in, and then used to relay the results. Luke's narrator imagines how many people have been in these cubicles and what they would look like if they were all piled on top of one another, piles of tested bodies.
负责卢克匿名编号的护士是一位黑人变装皇后，名叫斯蒂芬妮，她穿着一套完整的护士装，头上顶着一顶小纸帽，戴在她精心打理的发型上。她是诊所里唯一穿正规制服的人。斯蒂芬妮有着卢克见过任何人当中最长的指甲。卢克简短地想到了指甲在人死后还会继续生长，但他用手指按住额头把这个想法推开，纳闷自己为什么要那样想。又是那种小说情节。
Cut to Stephanie closing the hollow core door. It makes that hollow core door sound. Do you have that on a cart? [DOOR CLOSES] Perfect. Maybe a shot from a security camera that shows all of the cubicles in the clinic.
变装皇后护士斯蒂芬妮带着卢克走进进行测试的小隔间，那里也用于转达结果。卢克的旁白想象着有多少人进过这些隔间，如果把他们全都堆在一起会是什么样子，一堆接受过测试的尸体。
Luke imagines himself in a George Tooker painting that was reproduced in his sixth grade reader. He wonders what his sixth grade teacher would think of Stephanie. He wonders if his sixth grade teacher was ever tested. He imagines her body in the pileup of bodies who have come to the clinic.
转场至斯蒂芬妮关上空心门。发出那种空心门的声音。你有那个音效吗？[门关上]完美。或许从安全摄像头的角度拍一张显示诊所里所有隔间的镜头。
Stephanie's been saying something, and Luke has to blink his eyes again to refocus. He explains to Stephanie that he's been expecting this result, that he's experienced a large share of AIDS cared for and likewise buried lots of his friends, but it doesn't seem to come as a surprise. Stephanie says, "You can cry or hold my hand. I just want you to sit for a moment and let it sink in." Luke thinks, whatever.
卢克想象自己置身于六年级课本中转载的那幅乔治·塔克的画里。他想知道他的六年级老师会怎么看斯蒂芬妮。他想知道他的六年级老师是否做过测试。他想象着她的身体在来到诊所的尸体堆里。
Cut to Bill in waiting room, flipping through People's "The Year in Pictures." Cut back to close-up of Luke, forehead wrinkled. He thinks his narrator wants him to get out of the cubicle. He waits for Stephanie to finish her spiel, thanks her, and shakes her hand, getting a slight scrape from one of the fingernails. Close-up on Luke's hand, new scratch. The walls seem to pulsate as Luke walks down the hallway to the reception area. He tries to be as blank as possible to Bill.
斯蒂芬妮一直在说着什么，卢克不得不再次眨眼聚焦。他向斯蒂芬妮解释说他一直预料到这个结果，他经历过照顾许多艾滋病患者，也埋葬过许多朋友，但这似乎并不让他感到惊讶。斯蒂芬妮说：“你可以哭，或者握住我的手。我只是想让你坐一会儿，让这个事实沉淀一下。”卢克心想，随它去吧。
I'm not sure about this final section. I know that we talked about it ending on the highway with the car being surrounded by bikers on their way to the Sturgis bikers rally, but now I like the idea of it ending on the highway entrance ramp. OK.
转场至候诊室里的比尔，翻看着《人物》杂志的《年度图片》。转场回卢克的特写，眉头紧锁。他觉得他的旁白想让他离开隔间。他等着斯蒂芬妮说完她的套话，感谢她，并与她握手，被其中一个指甲轻轻划伤。卢克的手部特写，新伤痕。当卢克沿着走廊走向接待区时，墙壁似乎在搏动。他尽量向比尔表现得空白一些。
Cut to interior of car pulling out of parking lot. Luke keeps looking straight ahead as he murmurs, "I'm positive." Long slow pan from the back of Luke's head to the back of Bill's. There's no reaction in either of their faces, or better, the profiles of their faces. This is the longest shot. They don't look at each other.
我不确定最后这一部分。我知道我们谈过以公路为结尾，车子被一群正前往斯特吉斯摩托车集会的骑手包围，但现在我喜欢以高速公路入口匝道为结尾的想法。好的。
Perhaps this scene would be shot in blue screen with the camera in the backseat, and the sky surrounding the two heads of Bill and Luke having that old scratchy 16 millimeter time lapse exposure so the clouds seem to be moving at a rapid pace. Flickers, flips back and forth between real sky and blue screen backdrop. Voice comes up on a car radio, try not to think of the future. Just live in the present moment, something like that. You got that? It comes on to the radio.
转场至离开停车场的汽车内部。卢克直视前方，喃喃自语道：“我呈阳性。”从卢克的后脑勺慢慢平移到比尔的后脑勺。他们两人的脸上都没有表情，或者更好的是，他们的侧脸轮廓。这是最长的镜头。他们没有看对方。
I also decided that it was entirely unnatural and inhumane way to live, and that having a future is part of what being human is about. And that when you take away the future for humans, you take away a lot of their humanness. And that it's not actually a very good thing to live entirely in the present, that one needs to have a past.
或许这个场景可以用蓝幕拍摄，摄像机放在后座，包围比尔和卢克头部的天空有着那种古老的、带有划痕的16毫米延时曝光，所以云朵似乎在快速移动。闪烁，在真实天空和蓝幕背景之间翻转。收音机里传出声音，尽量不去想未来。就活在当下，诸如此类的。你有那个吗？它在收音机里响起来。
Luke comments to Bill, "Live entirely in the present, huh?" Bill drives and looks out the corner of his right eye to see what position Luke is holding his head in. Luke looks outside passenger window, and every once in a while turns to glance at Bill. Long pause. There's dead air.
我还决定，这是一种极其不自然和非人道的生活方式，拥有未来是身为人类的一部分。当你夺走人类的未来时，你也夺走了他们很大一部分人性。而完全活在当下实际上并不是一件好事，一个人需要有过去。
Cut to Luke's point of view. Car is pulling on to entrance ramp of highway. Luke sees hitchhiker with a sign that he scans for any remote meaning to the narrative. Luke sees himself outside of his own story. He can't read the hitchhiker's sign. He knows that he's on a long, silent journey. He leans over to turn off the radio. Cut to black.
卢克对比尔评论道：“活在当下，是吧？”比尔开着车，用右眼余光瞥了一眼，看卢克把头保持在什么位置。卢克看着乘客窗外，偶尔转过头瞥一眼比尔。长暂停。是一段死寂。
Act Three.
转场至卢克的视角。汽车正驶入高速公路入口匝道。卢克看到一个拿着牌子的搭车人，他扫描着寻找任何与叙事相关的遥远意义。卢克看到自己置身于自己的故事之外。他读不懂搭车人的牌子。他知道他踏上了一段漫长、沉默的旅程。他俯身关掉收音机。转场至黑屏。
This is is a show Claudia Perez is doing on my brother Javier.
第三幕。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
这是克劳迪娅·佩雷斯正在制作的一档关于我哥哥哈维尔的节目。
Shut up. No wonder your friends can't listen to this.
[听不清]
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
闭嘴。难怪你的朋友听不下去这个。
Did you ever have any thoughts like oh, I want to die?
[听不清]
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
你有过任何想法，比如噢，我想死吗？
No, I don't got to-- have you ever imagined your death, like--
[听不清]
[INAUDIBLE]
不，我没必要——你有没有想象过你的死亡，比如——
[INAUDIBLE] In April of 1996, how did your day begin the day that you got shot?
[听不清]
[BLEEP] [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
[听不清] 在1996年4月，你中枪那天你是怎么开始的？
That's a recording of Claudia Perez, who's 19 years old, an occasional contributor to this program, interviewing her 21-year-old brother. And her brother had an experience where he and his family thought he might die.
[哔声] [听不清]
And Claudia, what is on this tape?
那是19岁、偶尔为本节目投稿的克劳迪娅·佩雷斯的录音，她在采访她21岁的哥哥。她的哥哥经历过一次他自己和家人都以为他会死的事件。
He was being a big brat. He's laying down on the bed, and I'm sitting on his wheelchair, and I'm interviewing him. And he keeps trying to grab the microphone from me.
克劳迪娅，这张磁带里是什么内容？
Tell me what happened, like what you see, what you thought of that moment when you got shot? What happened?
他像个大顽童一样。他躺在床上，我坐在他的轮椅上采访他。他一直想从我手里抢麦克风。
What happened? Well, I got a hole in my body, and I was bleeding.
告诉我发生了什么，比如你看到的，你中枪那一刻你在想什么？发生了什么？
That is so stupid. Let go of me.
发生了什么？好吧，我的身体上出了个洞，我在流血。
So how did you bring him around? What did you do?
那太愚蠢了。放开我。
I had to open up the story. I had to take him back so he could remember.
你是怎么引导他谈论的？你做了什么？
Why don't you take us back? What exactly happened to him?
我不得不开启这个话题。我不得不带他回到过去，这样他才能记起来。
Well, it was April 2 or April 6 of '96, and he had come to the house in the morning. And he had bought some gym shoes, and he was showing off, ha ha, look, I got some gym shoes. And you're not supposed to buy gym shoes because that's not fair, because you're not buying stuff for my little brother. And I was like, you're being greedy. Something's going to happen to you for being greedy.
为什么不带我们回到过去？他到底发生了什么？
And I remember that I felt weird that day. You know how they say women have this kind of sense? I don't know, but I felt weird.
好吧，那是96年4月2日或6日，他早上到过家里。他买了一些运动鞋，正在炫耀，哈哈，看，我有新运动鞋了。你不应该买运动鞋，因为那不公平，因为你没给我弟弟买东西。我就说，你太贪心了。你会因为贪心而遭遇报应的。
So it was quick. It happened quick. Go for the gun quick, and then turn around and take off. But as soon as I turned around, that's when I got shot. Then everything happened so fast. I seen like a white light. Everybody says they seen a light, but it is weird, because you see like a little light. Everything's like in slow motion. I was trying to-- like oh, this is a dream. I'm going to go back to sleep. I'm going to wake up, and then I'm going to be home in bed next to my wife and kids. And this is only a bad dream. I can shake it off.
我记得那天我感觉很奇怪。你知道人们常说女人有这种直觉吗？我不知道，但我感觉很奇怪。
One of his friends, they were going to go party at a bar, and they went towards the back of the gangway. They were over there in the back of the gangway, and--
事情发生得很快。去拿枪很快，然后转身逃跑。但就在我转身的时候，我就中枪了。一切发生得太快了。我看到像是一道白光。每个人都说他们看到了光，但这很奇怪，因为你确实看到了一点光。一切都像是慢动作。我试图——就像噢，这是一个梦。我要回去睡觉。我要醒来，然后我要在家里和妻子孩子躺在床上。这只是一个噩梦。我可以把它甩掉。
The game way is?
他的一个朋友，他们本来要去酒吧聚会，他们走向小巷的后方。他们在那里，在小巷的后方，然后——
A house. Of a house.
小巷是？
OK. Oh, the gangway.
一所房子。房子的。
Yeah. And they were just all talking there, and the guy stuck out the gun to my brother, and my brother tried to take it from his hand.
好的。噢，小巷。
Wait, now this guy came out of where? Was he in a car? Was he walking?
是的。他们都在那里谈话，那个人掏枪指向我哥哥，我哥哥试图把它从他手里抢过来。
No, they were all just over there in the back of the gangway. They were talking, and he tried to rob my brother. And my brother tried to take the gun from him, and the guy did it. While my brother was trying to run, he shot him in the stomach, which hit his spinal cord.
等等，这个人是从哪儿出来的？他在车里吗？他在走路吗？
Like I said, I was thinking. I was thinking that I had to get to the front of the house, because then if I lay here and bleed, I'll probably just bleed to death. I'll just bleed to death. So I figured that I would try to figure out a way to get to the front of the house. So I dragged myself on my arms. I dragged myself, and then some guy was passing by. I told him, "Hey, help me, I got shot." He didn't believe me. A big old commotion started happening. I caught an ambulance. And then all of a sudden, my wife and my kid and my sister just got there. I don't know how they found out I was there.
不，他们都在小巷后方。他们在谈话，他试图抢劫我哥哥。我哥哥试图从他手里抢枪，那个人就开枪了。我哥哥在试图逃跑时，他打中了我哥哥的肚子，击中了脊髓。
When he was in the ICU unit, he looked real bad. And he was like all bloody, and blood was coming out, whatever. And he's dark-skinned, my brother. And at the ICU he looked pale. He had no color. And my mom was crying, because she's like, "Oh, my son. He's Negrito, like he's dark-skinned. Where's his color at? Where's his color?" And she was crying, "Where's my son's color at?" And begging, "Oh, my son's not dark no more. Got to give him his color back, because we will know that he's healthy with his color back."
就像我说的，我当时在思考。我在想我必须走到房子前面去，因为如果我躺在这儿流血，我可能会流血至死。我可能就会流血致死。所以我心想，我会想办法走到房子前面。所以我用双臂拖着自己。我拖着自己，然后有人经过。我告诉他，“嘿，帮帮我，我中枪了。”他不相信我。一场大混乱开始了。我叫了一辆救护车。然后突然，我的妻子、我的孩子和我妹妹都到了。我不知道他们是怎么发现我在那儿的。
And it was three days, it was three or four days in the ICU. They came and told me that I'm going to be paralyzed.
他在重症监护室的时候，看起来很糟糕。他浑身都是血，血流了出来之类的。我的哥哥，他的肤色很深。在重症监护室他看起来很苍白。他一点血色都没有。我妈在哭，因为她说，“噢，我儿子。他是Negrito，肤色很深。他的血色呢？他的肤色去哪儿了？”她在哭，“我儿子的血色去哪儿了？”并在恳求，“噢，我儿子不再是深肤色了。必须把他的血色还给他，因为如果他的血色回来，我们就知道他健康了。”
What was your reaction to that? How did it make you feel?
在重症监护室住了三天，是三四天吧。他们来告诉我我将瘫痪。
I don't know. I didn't know how to react to it, because it had never happened to me. I mean, how am I supposed to know my [BLEEP] reaction?
你对那个的反应是什么？这让你感觉如何？
He usually talks about it freely, nice. But I guess because it's me he won't talk about it normally, because me and him, we never talk about it. I want him to tell me, because I never asked him that before. And I wanted him to tell me something that I always wanted to know, and I was mad, because he gave me a dumb answer. I thought, then tell me something more--
我不知道。我不知道该怎么反应，因为它以前从未发生在我身上。我是说，我该怎么知道我他妈的反应？
Heartfelt.
他通常谈论这个谈得很自由，很好。但我猜因为采访我的人是他，他不会正常谈论它，因为我和他，我们从来没谈过这个。我想要他说给我听，因为我从来没问过他。我想要他说一些我一直想知道的事，我很生气，因为他给了我一个愚蠢的答案。我想，那就告诉我一些更——
Yeah, and he didn't tell me that. He just made me feel like, oh, my god, you're never going to change, or something.
发自肺腑的。
What have you learned from this experience?
是的，他没有那样告诉我。他只是让我觉得，噢，天哪，你永远不会改变，之类的。
Well, I learned a lot of new words. I don't know. I know a lot of things about spinal cords and stuff I never paid attention to. You know, like stuff like you really never cared about.
你从这段经历中学到了什么？
Do you appreciate life more now?
好吧，我学到了很多新词。我不知道。我知道很多关于脊髓之类的我以前从没注意过的东西。你知道，就像你从来没在乎过的事情。
It's the same.
你现在更珍惜生命了吗？
Do you think your brother's changed since the accident?
一样。
He's changed, yeah. He doesn't drink anymore. He thinks more about the future, like before he would go day by day.
你觉得你哥哥自从那次事故后变了吗？
He doesn't drink at all?
他变了，是的。他不喝酒了。他更多地思考未来，比如以前他只是得过且过。
Not at all, and you could drink when you're paralyzed. You could. He says he doesn't smoke.
他一点酒也不喝了吗？
And why? Why not?
一点也不，你瘫痪了也是可以喝酒的。可以的。他说他不抽烟。
He don't want to. He says that he feels stupid. He looks at-- before, he used to go out with his boys and all his friends. He's never seen how stupid they look. And now that he doesn't drink, he sees how stupid they are, and that there's no point to drink and get like that anymore. He says that-- one day he told me that if he ever walked again, he wouldn't take it for granted. He told me that once. He goes, I'll kiss the ground, or something like that. He told me once.
为什么？为什么不喝？
And I was like, whoa, because we never talk like nice to each other. We're always fighting or something about something. And that one day that he told me that, I was like, oh. I felt weird. When he talks nice to me, it feels weird. Like when I was doing the interview, I couldn't look at him, because I was like, oh, you get on my nerves. It's that kind of thing, like we love each other, but we can't stand each other. And when we fight, he still beats me up, even though he's in a wheelchair. He still beats me up. I don't know. It's strange.
他不想。他说他觉得自己很蠢。他看看——以前，他总是和他的哥们和朋友们出去玩。他从未见过他们看起来有多蠢。现在他不喝酒了，他能看到他们有多蠢，而且再也没有意义去喝酒变得那样了。他说——有一天他告诉我，如果他能再次行走，他不会把它视为理所当然。他告诉过我一次。他说，我会亲吻大地，或者类似的话。他告诉我一次。
That hasn't changed.
然后我当时就想，哇，因为我们从来不对彼此好说话。我们总是为了什么事情打架或者吵架。那天他告诉我那个，我当时就想，噢。我感觉很奇怪。当他对我好说话时，感觉很奇怪。就像我做采访的时候，我不敢看他，因为我在想，噢，你让我心烦。就是那种感觉，就像我们爱彼此，但我们受不了对方。当我们打架时，他还会打我，尽管他在轮椅里。他还是会打我。我不知道。这很奇怪。
People tell me, how can he beat you up still? And I'm like, he does.
那点还没变。
How does he beat you up? Well, answer that. How can he pull that off?
人们问我，他怎么还能打你？我说，他就是会打。
I don't know. He does. I don't know. He's just real-- it's weird. It's like I learned after my brother's death experience, almost near, I wrote a poem to him. And I have it at home, but it's like I named it sick brother. And I said-- I don't remember exactly what I said in it, but I was writing letters to him when he was in the ICU unit, because I didn't want to go in there. I didn't want to go in there. And I told him when he was like laying there, and I told him I loved him. And I never told him that, but I had to tell him that. And I was like, man, in case something happens, I want him to know that even though he gets on my nerves, I do love my brother.
他怎么打你的？好吧，回答一下。他是怎么做到的？
And when you said this to him in the hospital, he was awake, and he could--
我不知道。他就是会。我不知道。他就是非常——这很奇怪。就像我在我哥哥的死亡体验之后，几乎接近死亡，我写了一首诗给他。我在家有留底，但我把它命名为《生病的哥哥》。我说——我不记得我确切在诗里说了什么，但我写信给他是在他在重症监护室的时候，因为我不想进去。我不想进去。我在他躺在那儿的时候告诉他，我爱他。我从来没告诉过他，但我必须那样做。我在想，伙计，万一发生什么事，我要让他知道，尽管他让我心烦，我确实爱我的哥哥。
No, I wrote it to him.
当你你在医院里对他说了这些，他醒着，他能——
You wrote it to him, and he saw it and he read it?
不，我写信给他。
He read it.
你写信给他，他看到了，读了？
And did he say anything about it afterwards?
他读了。
No.
他之后有说什么吗？
And then when he came out of the hospital, it was just like back to normal?
没有。
Normal.
然后当他出院时，一切就恢复正常了？
Like it never happened?
正常。
Yeah, like whatever. One day I told him, "Oh, I love you, brother." "ooh, get away from me." He told me, "Get away from me."
就像什么都没发生过？
So even nearly dying hasn't changed anything between the two of you?
是的，就像随便吧。有一天我告诉他，“噢，我爱你，哥哥。”“噢，离我远点。”他告诉我说，“离我远点。”
That is true, very true.
所以即使濒临死亡也没有改变你们俩之间的任何事？
Is there any advice you would give to any young people out there who are trying to use their lives the same way you did, and they get up in the next incident like this?
那是真的，非常真实。
Just don't be in the wrong place at the wrong time.
你有什么建议给那些正在以同样方式挥霍生命，并且可能在下一次事故中遭遇这种事的年轻人吗？
Claudia Perez is a college freshman at Moraine Valley majoring in fashion design. She also works as a hostess at the Continental House of Pancakes on Chicago's south side.
别在错误的时间出现在错误的地点。
Act Four, Hope. A friend of a friend of mine was misdiagnosed with a disease and nearly died, and it got so bad that in the end she couldn't get out of bed, had said goodbye to everybody she knew, had given away everything, spent all her money. And she said that when the doctor told her you'll live, it was actually harder than when he told her you're going to die. She thought, what now? Well, Cheryl Trykv had a similar experience, and has our next story.
克劳迪娅·佩雷斯是莫兰谷社区学院的大一学生，主修时装设计。她也在芝加哥南区的洲际煎饼屋担任领位员。
Dr. Fargate tells me how lucky I am. He says surgery was touch and go, and that for an hour or so there I was this close-- with his fore and middle fingers side by side sticking out from the rest of his fist, he demonstrates the proximity. "You nearly died," he says, smiling, teasing me, "But it looks like you'll live." Oh? Why, that's wonderful. Life, one missed opportunity after the other, was this close.
第四幕，《希望》。我的一个朋友的朋友被误诊得了某种病，差点死掉，情况变得如此糟糕，以至于最后她下不了床，告别了她认识的每一个人，捐赠了一切，花光了所有的钱。她说当医生告诉她你会活下去时，这实际上比他告诉她你快要死掉时还要困难。她心想，现在该干什么？好吧，谢丽尔·特里夫也有类似的经历，并带来了我们的下一个故事。
My roommate in the hospital tells me how lucky I am. She says that when she arrived there was no toilet paper or paper towels in the bathroom. "How am I supposed to wipe myself without no toilet paper?" she asked. Indeed. Great to be alive. Later I request a private room. But her line of thinking gets me asking questions of my own, big questions. The biggest questions come at meal time, such as, what is it?
法尔盖特医生告诉我我有多幸运。他说手术过程惊心动魄，那一两个小时里我离死只有这么一点——用他的食指和中指并排从拳头里伸出来，他演示了那个距离。“你差点死掉，”他笑着，打趣我说，“但看来你能活下去。”噢？哇，那太美妙了。生活，一个接一个错失的机会，竟然离我这么近。
One evening the nurse comes in with my dinner tray. I situate myself upright in bed so as to feed myself, and lift the cover off the entree. They've served me my own pancreas. What's more is they try to pass it off as Italian beef. I tell the nurse there's been a mistake. I think I may have somebody else's tray. "No," she says, "no mistake."
医院里的室友告诉我我有多幸运。她说她来的时候卫生间里没有卫生纸或纸巾。“没卫生纸我怎么擦屁股？”她问。确实。活着真是太棒了。后来我要求换个单人病房。但她的思维逻辑让我自己也提出了问题，大问题。最大的问题出现在用餐时间，比如，这是什么？
So many questions. So many, many questions. Oh, the morphine drip provides five or six brilliant answers, but I can't remember them now.
一天晚上护士送来了我的餐盘。我把自己撑在床上以便喂自己吃，掀开了主菜的盖子。他们端给我我自己的胰腺。更重要的是，他们试图把它当作意大利炖牛肉蒙混过关。我告诉护士出了点错。我想我可能拿错了别人的餐盘。“不，”她说，“没搞错。”
I blather away the hours in a semi-fog of hope that maybe the doctors missed something. Maybe I'm not so lucky after all. Maybe they're wrong about me. Maybe I won't have to return to that world of tending bar, and waiting tables, and customers with their selfish tastes and relentless hungers for penny ante attention. No more train and bus connections.
太多的问题。太多太多的问题。噢，吗啡点滴提供了五六个绝妙的答案，但我现在记不起来了。
The flowers and get well cards will keep coming in all day long, the few days I'll have remaining. And friends will flock in from the trees or wherever it is they've been hiding, and tell me over and over again how much they love me. They'll tell me not so much in words but in the way they massage my feet, get me ice cream, and bring me gifts. "Not another book on the mind-body connection. Oh, put it with the stack of others there in the corner. Did you find out if Toshiro had any more of those little bed jackets for me?"
我在一种希望医生可能搞错了什么的半梦半醒的状态中虚度光阴。也许我根本没那么幸运。也许他们关于我的诊断错了。也许我不必回到那个服务员、餐桌侍应生的世界，回到那些有自私品味、无休止渴望着一点点关注的顾客身边。再也没有火车和公交线路了。
Dr. Fargate comes and goes with his probing brigade. I think the Pakistani has a crush on me. Anyway, he's barely an intern.
鲜花和康复贺卡会整天不停地送来，在我生命仅剩的那几天里。朋友们会从树林或任何他们躲藏的地方涌来，一遍又一遍地告诉我他们有多爱我。他们告诉我的不是用语言，而是用他们按摩我脚的方式、给我买冰淇淋、给我带礼物。“不是又一本关于身心联结的书吗？噢，把它堆在角落里那一摞书里吧。你发现托希罗还有没有更多那种小外套给我？”
Later Dr. Fargate returns alone with something serious to tell me. "We've taken a second look at your biopsy report. I'm afraid we're looking at stage four. It's critical." "Oh, thank God. I thought you were going to talk about my bill." He tells me at this point I should do anything to lift my spirits.
法尔盖特医生带着他的问诊团队来来去去。我觉得那个巴基斯坦人对我有好感。不管怎样，他只是个实习生。
That night there is a champagne party in my room for the entire ward. I let one of the nurses wear my bed cap, the one with mink along the brim. A few of us are busted for smoking in the bathroom. Drunk on Fools Wit long after the others have returned to their rooms, I prank phone call various former employers, leaving messages of hell-born prophecy on their voice mail. I make a list of hardships and collection agencies I will escape if I were to die. How soon is now?
后来法尔盖特医生独自回来，有件严肃的事要告诉我。“我们重新看了你的活检报告。我恐怕我们看到的是四期。情况危急。”“噢，感谢上帝。我还以为你要谈我的账单了。”他告诉我在此刻我应该做任何事来振奋精神。
At night I dream I am a beekeeper developing a strain of worker bees that automatically die before their pension fund kicks in. Because the fund only amounts to a thimble full of pollen, the early death is useful. I wake with the image of me standing before a subcommittee selling a special gas made from identical molecular bee genetics that can be sprayed on postal employees. I hold a sign that reads, works until drops dead.
那天晚上，我在病房里为整个病区举办了一场香槟派对。我让其中一个护士戴上我的睡帽，帽檐上有貂皮的那顶。我们有几个人因为在卫生间抽烟被抓住了。在其他人回到病房很久之后，我仍然沉醉在愚人智慧中，恶作剧电话打给几位前雇主，在他们的语音信箱里留下地狱般的预言信息。我列了一份清单，写着如果我死了我将逃避的苦难和讨债公司。现在有多快？
Act Five, On the Edge of the World.
晚上我梦见自己是一个养蜂人，正在培育一种会自动死掉的工蜂，在养老金生效之前就死掉。因为基金只有一顶针那么多的花粉，过早死亡很有用。醒来时，我的脑海中浮现出我站在小组委员会前，兜售一种由相同的分子蜂遗传基因制成的特殊气体，可以喷在邮政员工身上。我举着一个写着“工作直到倒毙”的牌子。
How do I sustain interest in a world that I'm scheduled not to be a part of very soon?
第五幕，《世界边缘》。
Matthew Goulish says that when he  had cancer, he found that he couldn't cry. He would hear bad news about people who he knew, fellow patients who he heard had died, and he says that he just didn't feel much. It was as if he had arrived at a state where all the events of the world seemed of equal weight, of equal importance. Well, we thought we would give Matthew the last word in today's program.
我怎么能在某种很快就被安排不再参与的世界中保持兴趣？
In 1994, six years after I had been cured, an acquaintance of mine contracted lymphoma. I wrote her a letter which I never delivered-- until now.
马修·古利什说，当他得了癌症时，他发现自己哭不出来。他听到关于他认识的人，那些一同住院的病人去世的消息，他说他感觉不到太多。这就好比他抵达了一种状态，世界上的所有事件似乎都具有相同的分量、相同的重要性。好吧，我们想把今天节目的最后发言权留给马修。
Dear Brigid, as our small party waited for the table, talking among ourselves at the Greek restaurant last night, I noticed you looking at the display of fresh foods-- heaps of hazelnuts, walnuts, leaves of oregano, bottles of oils on the dark wood cutting block. You watched the cook chopping up onions, and I recognized the look on your face. Events had equalized for you. You had been pulled three quarters out of the world, and I wanted to say what's happening to you is not fair. It's not time yet, and statements of that kind.
1994年，在我治愈六年后，我的一位熟人患上了淋巴瘤。我写了一封信给她，我从未寄出——直到现在。
But when you are leaving the world you understand that it isn't death that is strange and fearsome, but life. How is this struggling life possible? How are these people possible? How am I possible? I am not.
亲爱的布里吉德，昨晚在我们的小团体在希腊餐厅等待餐桌时，大家在谈话，我注意到你在看着陈列的新鲜食物——成堆的榛子、核桃、牛至叶、暗色木头砧板上的油瓶。你看着厨师切洋葱，我认出了你脸上的那种神情。事件对你来说已经拉平了。你已经被拉出了世界四分之三的距离，我想说你所经历的事情是不公平的。现在还不到时候，以及这类陈述。
Our program was produced by Nancy Updike, Alix Spiegel, and myself. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin. Music help from John Connors, Peter Margasak, and Steve Cushing. Thanks to Bridget Murphy.
但当你离开这个世界时，你明白奇怪和可怕的不是死亡，而是生活。这种挣扎的生活怎么可能存在？这些人怎么可能存在？我怎么可能存在？我并不存在。
The first version of this episode of our radio show aired back in 1995. In the years since then, I am sorry to report Lawrence Steger, the writer and performer in Act Two, has died. A very wonderful man.
我们的节目由南希·厄普代克、亚历克斯·斯皮格尔和我本人制作。特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。音乐帮助来自约翰·康纳斯、彼得·马加萨克和史蒂夫·库欣。感谢布里奇特·墨菲。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
这档广播节目的第一集版本早在1995年就播出了。在随后的岁月里，我很遗憾地报告，第二幕中的作家和表演者劳伦斯·斯蒂格已经去世。一个非常出色的人。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
[资助名单]
PRI, Public Radio International.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。